welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss here with mt
we're gonna take some questions that you
had from episode three of the falcon
in the winter soldier a crazy episode
that jumped all around the world
introduced us to characters we had met
before the mcu but with completely new
characters behind those faces
nemo or sharon carter we also got a
little tease of a
familiar face from wakanda uh so that's
fun
be sure to watch our inside marvel after
show and the easter egg breakdown
if you're watching this on youtube right
now we're taking questions from our
wonderful listeners on stereo yes so
here we go let's take our first question
you're ready
to do it i think sharon carter is the
proud broker
what do you think no
no idea but i think she could be
connected to the power but we talked
about this a bit
in the inside marvel after show i i
think she's got a weird story that she
needs to yeah
she's weirdly powerful it's weird that
she has this uh whole art collection now
and that's the world that she lives in
when she could just live low profile off
the grid
um but she uh i think she could work for
the power broker what do you think empty
yeah i definitely don't think that
sharon carter is the power broker it'd
be
really weird and i honestly feel like if
sharon carter was the power broker and
she had access to these
um super soldier vials that she probably
would have put gave herself some
um if there isn't some type of like
terrible flaw in it that we don't know
about anyway
so it like it just it doesn't make sense
just given what she
what she did in episode three for her to
be the power broker but i do
understand why there is um a huge
a growing uh movement of people that do
think that she is
the power broker but i i just don't
think that it really adds up there
yeah if you think like if she is the
power like the power broker they're
implying it's this figure who has
graffiti everywhere saying that he's
watching people or she's watching people
that we don't know what they are but
they like uh it's a surveillance thing
it's like
this figure that has been mythologized
about for decades
sharon carter has only moved to madrid
in the last few years
while she has risen far in that time i
don't see her
why would she be doing all this stuff
herself putting herself in danger
if she's a criminal lord of this
of this colony like yes the power
brokers not someone who's going to
put themselves in front of gunfire just
to defend bucky and sam and zemo
in the shipyard yard like that's i think
she could be working for them obviously
she is connected to someone because she
was like we have a couple problems i'll
tell you about in the car at the end so
i get
she's shady she's shady mega shady
i think it's more likely the power
broker is either some new face
um someone we don't know yet a
completely new character new face or it
could be someone like the mandarin
i think the mandarin is kind of this
head of the ten rings uh
a criminal network whose spies go all
over the world
who are always watching um i think that
kind of lines up more than sharon carter
yeah and i and we do have a light
connection and like i'm not saying that
this is even
a thing but like with the extremist
project and the mandarin there is
a some type of connection to the
mandarin-esque figure
even though it wasn't the real mandarin
and um you know altering
um body chemistry and enhancing human
beings so
potentially we could have a mandarin who
you know
took killian's um inspiration because
killian took inspiration from him
he's like you know what maybe i'll
become the pop like i'll deal with the
powers and like i'll
focus on you know taking these um this
work that
um nagel did with the cia and um
you know making profit off of this
potentially so
the 10 rings has been interested in uh
in weapons tech for as long as we've
known them they wanted
tony stark's tech in the first iron man
that's why raza
couldn't yes um the
they wanted pimtec and ant-man in the
first ant-man movie
and they won that yellow jacket suit so
yeah it would make sense but
like any criminal mastermind yeah
they're going to be interested in any
kind of like super
tech that they can weaponize and sell or
use
um yes but uh yeah sharon carter
has an interesting story i hope this
isn't the last we see of her
i hope this wasn't a one and done
character i would love to go back to
match report or she can come back to the
us
um and tell her story but uh yeah for
a long time i theorized that she could
be a scroll i think it'd be weird for
the power broker
it's possible the power broker could be
kind of some kind of scroll
lord um it's just like i'm ready to
rest scrolls for now uh we just got
back-to-back scroll cameos and titles
if we maybe wait to see more squirrels
until
i i don't know miss marvel or something
later this year
i'd be okay with it yeah like i'd be
honestly be okay with waiting for
scrolls until secret invasion
drops with yeah nick fury and all them
yeah
like it's it's cool to see them pop up
here and there but like i don't want
them to be like you know
because like this is a very specific
part of the marvel universe this is more
grounded this is just more
it's less cosmic so like i know that
secret invasion
is something that does you know
encompass
all of like i i feel like
kevin feige has some restraint to be
like all right there's a time and place
for scrolls there's a time and place for
setting up future marvel movies and
we've already done that with wand
division
so um hopefully we don't see any here
honestly that's just me let's take
another question
hey eric mt first i want to say thank
you for the
breakdowns of the episodes and eric you
ever
did the um episode 2 breakdown you had
brought up the mutant growth thing
what if um john walker and battle star
have been taking doses of that
given to them by the cia
oh you know if yes so the mutant growth
serum uh that i uh that i remember
bringing up is in relation to the comic
backstory for
patriot for eli walker now in the comics
mutants show up everywhere because
there's
not that kind of like uh division that
there have been in the mcu up until this
point
um i'd be i don't think it's going to be
the mutant growth serum i think
they've been given some other kind of
enhancement i don't think it'll be
specifically the mutant growth serum
just because
they need to introduce what mutants are
and what they mean to this universe
before they bring in things that are
called the mutant growth
i i definitely don't think the mutant
growth serum is going to be a factor
quite yet like you said because like we
have to introduce the concept of mutants
and i think that that isn't probably
going to happen until the eternals drops
and we get
you know more backstory of the the
cosmic
physiology of human beings and like you
know about the x gene and all that stuff
and you know i do think that kevin feige
probably wants to do that
when on on a bigger stage like i always
say like theater is the
is the best stage for um
in the the state that people know the
most for marvel studios
projects so whenever um theaters do open
back up again and
and and more eyes are able to see a big
marvel event like a movie
then uh that's when we're gonna get
mutants and that's when we're gonna get
you know all the mutant elements
so i definitely don't think mgh is going
to be a factor but
i do like that he brought up the cia
connection yeah and
um and john walker because like if the
cia was working
with super soldier serum then there is a
chance that
um they have either like an unfinished
or or not so great
version of the formula to potentially
give battlestar and
john walker so yeah cci
is an interesting one i think they just
mentioned a government influence now the
cia
is cia is part of the intelligence
um community in the u.s government yeah
um
they are kind of their own actor but i
think they're under defense
technically rather than sticking so i'm
trying to think secretary of state
thaddeus ross
uh wouldn't have like control over
things the cia does
kind of yeah i think he would have some
influence absolutely
um yeah but yeah i was wondering if it's
cia
he could totally have his hands tied in
with whatever that program was
and he didn't say when this was it could
have been before he rose up to become
secretary of state and there was that
period where he said he
went missing due to like a heart attack
or something like that
um did he really go off the grid to work
on some other thing
you know i wonder if
if that that cia stuff had anything to
do with um
you know blonsky and and what what went
on with um
i mean like well that was more of like
the incredible hulk in hulk's um
research but it would be interesting to
see if there are
connections to the cia's work and the
2008 incredible hulk film but yeah we'll
see
yeah it seems like they're tying back a
lot to uh this whole
weapons plus uh project rebirth um kind
of thing
yeah wouldn't surprise me if it were in
that direction but hey before i continue
losing your hair can be a bummer patrick
stewart has been pulling off the bald
and handsome look since the late 80s but
we're not all gifted with as beautiful a
skull as that guy
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
i know guys in my life that are stressed
out about it but with keeps it is easier
and more affordable to get treatment for
your hair loss and to help you keep the
hair that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there and at half the cost of your
local pharmacy you used to have to go to
a doctor's office
for this kind of treatment but with
keeps you can do it all from home you
meet with the doctor online and they
ship the treatment right to you every
three months so you don't have to wait
in line at the pharmacy find out why
keep says more five star reviews than
any of its competitors and nearly one
hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication so if you're
noticing that you're losing your hair do
something about it for a limited time go
to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order um let's take
another question what do you guys
think is going to happen after all those
people recorded bucky
um beating up all those other guys in
that bar
that's a great question yeah i think
he's definitely in violation of the
terms of his pardon now
you know he was a little bit before but
once that video gets out i think
they're going to say winter soldiers
back winter soldiers live again fear
fear
and i think it's going to put a huge
target on his back and
john walker is going to get basically a
license to kill the winter soldier
and i think that's what's going to
happen and then i think in that
crossfire i think
zemo's going to kill him that's my
theory that zemo's going to kill john
walker in this show
spoiler it's just a prediction i don't
have i'm not
just predicting based off of stuff we've
seen and where i think it's going
i think that this might paint a bigger
um it'll definitely put a target on
a bucky's back but like sam in
association with bucky
and you know with with people trying to
with the government trying to sort of
i feel like there's like a all right we
have to paint sam as like
someone who's who isn't really worthy of
the shield anyway
so like if they had this footage with
sam in the background i was like yeah
i'm hanging out with
a known criminal winter soldier and like
i i approve of his beatdown
then like people can be like oh he
didn't deserve the shield anyway like
it's a good thing we gave it to a nice
white bred
john walker man because this guy hangs
out with criminals
um so yeah i'm i'm more interested to
see
how that affects sam cause like we
obviously know that it's probably gonna
affect bucky really badly
but you know just stand by association
and uh
you know how that how they might use
that to paint him as
um a bad black man um
for lack of a better term um i i i it'd
be really interesting
agree yeah let's take another question
who
do you think killed selby
oh i think that's going to be sure it's
got to be sharon
she was the sharp shooter in the window
and then later on the street there were
guys who were getting gunned down and
then sharon kind of ducked her head away
from the window i think the implication
is that
she had some eyes and ears on that
conversation once she saw that
sam's cover was blown he is uh not the
smiling tiger
action um but yeah yeah
yeah 100 shared let's take another
question
do you think that bucky will
return to wakanda and live in
peace as and the white
wolf you have such a good
voice that's what i was thinking i
didn't want to say it
you have an asmr quality to your voice i
was kind of lost
to sleep yes in a state i
i feel a lot more calmer eric i feel a
lot more at peace on the inside
oh my god my heart rate just went down
by like
i used to have high blood pressure not
anymore um
to answer your perfectly asked question
um
yeah i i hope bucky returns to wakanda
it seems to be the only place he's been
where he's at
any kind of peace since you know since
breaking free from hydra and yeah if he
retires
uh in wakanda i think living on as the
white wolf for them would be a great
future for him
i see i don't know um because like now
that he's broken zemo out of jail i
think that this man
is sort of just like not very liked
in wakanda at this present time i'm sure
that once he explains himself then maybe
but i i honestly think that his time in
wakanda is done
in that they did what they needed to do
for him and they they helped him out
and i think that he he really enjoys his
time in wakanda
but i do think this is something that
like i thought about
um as soon as i saw ao at the end of the
episode what if
ayo and um bucky have a secret
the history and like this is just
assuming that you know bucky
does like women um but you know if him
and ayo had this relationship um
and like because she does seem like um
like i
i'm not so happy to see you obviously
because of the zemo thing but like
i feel like there's there might be
something there um but that's just me
that's just me being
um a weirdo um but that's yeah right but
anyway
i think that seems pretty well uh okoye
has that relationship with wikabi
um i'm trying to think like are they
strict are they celibate you know they
just
only serve their roles and they don't
have other relationships or distractions
or something like
that but i don't know i didn't there
might be something there
um yeah but we'll we'll have to see i uh
i think there's plenty of storytelling
left for bucky right now i mean as of
right now i don't know where he's headed
uh
his character started out i loved seeing
this whole idea with a list
since he decided to break zemo out of
and now he's going back to he's
reverting his winter soldier stuff
i know he's playing he goes berserk you
know
uh just to fulfill a role i'm having
trouble
tracking what his whole i'm having
trouble tracking what all these
characters trajectories are to be honest
like i don't
it's kind of fun just to see them back
again and to see them
bouncing off each other but i don't
really have a clear sense of what
any of them want you know every episode
like their characters keep getting
redefined
and uh i don't know it's like it's it's
so weird uh you know
having these marvel shows now and and
having a narrative
be stretched out for so long because
like you know there are points where
just like
where are we going with this like what
what is going on with these characters
um so yeah no but i do understand
where you're coming from and like
the only people i know who what they
want are the flag smashers and i think
they are so boring like
which is a great more freedom fighters
who just want to play robin hood and
read
it's just like okay cool but it was
interesting when carly blew up that
place
yes that's what i was just gonna say
cool this is great i'm on board with
this
yes i i did like to see a more ruthless
side of
carly because at this point it was just
more like all right i'm sad
because like the things are in the blip
were better i'm just like all right but
show us how it was better because we
don't
you just seem like i'm just an angry
person at this point and like i just
show us like a flashback
or something that shows us that yeah
maybe they're right maybe life during
the blimp was better but we just don't
have
that perspective yet so i'm not yeah so
like they are a little bit
boring-ish but that blowing up of the uh
that building i was like all right maybe
you're a little less boring
yeah let's take another question red
skull's name was name dropped in this
episode so my question is do you think
we could possibly see red skull in the
show
um i think we might get more of an
explanation of
red skull's history i think that would
be cool i don't think they're bringing
in
we'll definitely not bring in a hugo
weaving i think he's done with the
character russ martin
i don't think he's going to show up as
red it's just not that kind of show
like yeah it's a show about super
soldiers it's a show about like criminal
underworlds it's grounded
in red skull was just kind of a goofy
thing that worked in the first cap film
um because it was like part of that past
and it had that kind of steam punky kind
of feel to it
and now red skull was perfect to bring
back an infinity war and end game
but that was this big cameo i just don't
see marvel being like
and we're gonna bring it back again like
it just feels like
a copy of a copy it feels derivative and
it's like there are so many other
characters you can bring back in cool
ways
red skull to come back and walk onto
screen
i think most people watching this show
would be like
i mean okay so i don't think that red
skull is going to be in this
show um exactly but i do believe
that red skull will return to the mcu at
some point like i've always believed
that yeah
yeah but like i just don't think in this
show
yeah definitely not in this show um i
feel like they want to
just make this a more just like a
like a more grounded and less like
because i feel like
red skull is specifically a captain
america villain
and i think that this show is setting up
sam to become captain america so when we
do have an actual captain america
um established that you know obviously
everyone's behind in like you know
sam wilson then i think that's when we
have
red skull being reintroduced and um
fight this new captain america but i
just think that
you know it's just too soon and we just
don't have
the the framework like the framework for
red skull's return hasn't been
laid out and like it's just it just be
sort of out of left field if they do do
that like you said i would just be like
all right this is just uh this is just a
big shock
and like to yeah i don't know it just it
would be sort of lazy writing
at that point right but i think so and
like just to be 100 clear
me and eric are we we're not bashing
falcon winner soldier it's a really
interesting program
it's just like there are two certain
elements that are just like all right
this is kind of like
uh kind of we we have some questions
but it is we are having a good time with
the show i'm uh yeah and i
the reason i'm doing this is like i
don't want us to
uh i don't think this happened with the
mephisto train people
but the people who really got excited
for quicksilver for the aerospace
engineer and yeah some of the mephisto
people
really let their expectations get ahead
of them with wanavision and stopped
seeing the great show that was in front
of them and only started to see
the promise of the show that they wanted
it to be and
i think the falcon winter soldier has so
much going for it it's got some great
action it's asking some interesting
questions it's exploring different parts
of this world that i'm really really
enjoying that and i think we should just
be grateful for the show that we have
and when we start going too far down the
theory rabbit hole we're going to start
in our head
canon's making it out to be something
that it's not and then we're going to be
disappointed when it doesn't live up to
those expectations
so we're trying we're trying to
encourage you all manage your
expectations with this show
it's okay to theorize totally okay to
theorize
but i don't want anyone going around out
there saying if red skull doesn't show
up in the show i'm going to unsubscribe
from disney plus
you know that would be a little bit uh
drastic please don't do that and you
would be missing out some great content
so
yeah um let's take another cute
i did notice the beginning of a rift
forming between john walker and lamar
hoskins
yeah lamar's trying to keep him in check
and john walker looks like he's going
off the deep end
definitely definitely true there yeah
and i think that
moment was to make us look at lamar
hoskins in a different light
to be like okay i'm still on board with
this guy this guy doesn't have the same
ideology the same temperament as john
walker does
so uh i think that gives us more of a
future for
lamar hoskins less of a future for john
walker yeah and like i
i do like that um hoskins is there to
to sort of show us that that walker is
sort of losing his his temper and losing
his cool
um and he's sort of just it like
it's it's good that he's there because
he he is tied to walker's past
and so he's known walker for a long time
so like he if anyone's going to notice
anything
wrong with john walker it's going to be
um lamar hoskins
so you know but yeah that that he is
sort of
like mentioned before in the in the
previous um segment
um walker is
i feel like he he's sort of he a he's
not
feeling respected and b he i feel like
he just
feels not empowered enough like not
strong enough
to fill up the role of captain america
and so i i think eventually if he's not
powered already
um he will seek out the the empowerment
by the power broker
uh because for him to to really feel
like a true steve rogers replacement
he wants to have that that strength so
um i think that's where
there might they might be going with
that with that rift that we're starting
to see between lamar
and and john but you know it could go
anywhere really
yeah totally agreed uh so i think we
have time for one more question here
since zima explained that sukurvius off
the map
could it be saying that it was renamed
into a different country like liveria
in the mcu i would love to hear your
thoughts keep up the great work
oh thank you um yeah i think you might
be onto something with
this liberia thing um because uh we know
sokovia is located in eastern europe
and he said other neighboring countries
kind of divided up the land mass and i
think
it might not be revealed as levaria now
but man it is the perfect setup to
uh to talk about the existence of
latveria and the mcu
which is awesome that region uh man i
would uh
i would love that that would be a sick
setup
and i yeah it would be great to see a
doctor doom
ask tease or something oh man
like that is a really great point i
didn't even consider that after the
episode so i'm glad you brought that up
friend yeah
he's a he's a smart man smart man
only smart people listen to our shows
only smart people only smart oh they
smart
um all right so we are going to cap it
there we want to thank everyone for
listening for sending in your questions
uh i got a breakdown i got to work on
it's going to be addressing a lot of
this stuff
um if you're watching this on youtube
the breakdown's already there go watch
it
make sure to watch that and uh follow mt
at mastertainment follow me at eavos
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
and uh follow us everywhere else uh make
sure to get your hands on our new latest
obsession anarchy assembled shirt
calm and uh we'll see you all next time
[Music]
bye
you